hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
demos saw a strange timepiece in the
museum
it had no numbers and it may have been
rotated out of position
also the second minute and hour hands
had the same length
but it operated like a standard
timepiece
what time was it
this problem was given to 13 and 14 year
olds in russia
thanks to yigor nazarov for suggesting
this
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so what time was showing
let's work this out logically
we'll label the hands as a b and c
notice that hands a and c are pointing
exactly to major marks on the dial
thus if either a or c were the hour hand
then the minute hand and the second hand
would have to overlap at exactly the
same number 12 and the clock would only
have two different hands showing
but that's not the case
consequently we can conclude that b has
to be the hour hand as it is not
pointing exactly to a major marking
next since both a and c are pointing
exactly to major markings the minute
hand is a whole number
thus the second hand must be at the
number 12 to indicate zero seconds
so now we have two cases to consider
one case is that a is the second hand
and it is pointing to 12.
we can label around to the hour hand of
b
now c is the minute hand and it's
pointing to the number 2.
in this case the time is 10 minutes past
the hour
but notice that the hour hand b in that
case should only be 1 6 of the way
between the hours of 6 and 7 it should
be closer to 6 than it is to 7.
as shown it's closer to 7
so this case cannot be true
the other case is that a is the minute
hand and c is the second hand so c is
pointing at 12 that means a is pointing
at 10 and b is between the hours of 4
and 5.
the time will be 50 minutes past the
hour and notice the hand b is actually 5
6 of the way to the next hour marking so
this works out exactly and that's the
answer
b is the hour hand a is the minute hand
c is the second hand and the time is 4
50.
furthermore we might conclude that the
time is 4 50 pm because the museum is
open
not many museums are open at 4 50 a.m
it's pretty neat that you can figure out
the time just from these hands without
any other markings
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you